Dave Ramsey he's able to make 10 million
a month just on media alone he has
somehow managed to have an education
information business without being seen
as a scam anybody else who sells a
course coaching events and an app that's
like the prototypical every other coach
whatever Guru out there and somehow he
managed to do that and build a $300
million a year business from basically
the same ingredients I wanted to really
get close to like what made it different
for Dave versus everybody else there's
two main things one is that the promise
that he was making was something that is
absolutely believable no one could fight
which is that if if you spend less money
you will have more left over it's very
different than most other promises which
is you do this thing then you make extra
$2,000 a month or whatever it is it's
like if you make 5,000 and you save a
th000 you have a th000 left over like
there's just no one can fight you right
and I think that really protects him
from a promises perspective yeah the
other side is that he absolutely focuses
on brand above everything